il est le braqueur le plus connu de
France redouine faillite 51 ans et jugé
pour sa spectaculaire évasion de prison
le 1er juillet 2018 en moins de 10
minutes ce malfaiteur récidiviste
s'envole avec trois complices à bord
d'un hélicoptère de la prison de Ro et
c'est une véritable expédition commando
avec sang frroid et professionnalisme
sans un seul coup de feu une fuite
sûrement préparée quelques mois plus tôt
avec des drones aperçus au-dessus de la
prison pourtant 3 mois après l'évasion
le 3 octobre 2018 le fuyard est
interpellé à crille sa ville natale la
bande avait laissé trop d'indices redoan
et son frère Rachid qui se cachait parf
fois derrière une burka avait même
failli se faire interpeller au volant
d'une voiture lors d'un banal contrôle
routier Redwan FID est le dernier d'une
frattererie de 11 enfants il baigne dans
la délinquence depuis la fin de
l'adolescence des séquestrations à
l'attaque de fourgon blindé les peines
sont de plus en plus lourdes en 2010 le
bracker publie même un livre braqueur
des cités au grand banditisme le grand
public découvre alors un repenti
autoproclamé son narcissisme et son goût
pour les films de gangster jusqu'à un
braquage raté en 2011 au cours duquel
une jeune policière municipale Aurélie
fouet est tuée àilier sur mar Redwan F
est condamné à 25 ans de réclusion pour
avoir organisé ce braquage meurtrier son
procès pour évasion de prison s'ouvre
donc ce mardi 5 septembre devant la Cour
d'assise de Paris il encourt la
perpétuité 11 autres individus
comparaissent dont deux de ses frères et
trois de ses neveux ainsi que Jacques
Mariani 57 ans fils de l'un des
fondateurs du célèbre gang Bastier de la
brise de mer verdict attendu le 20
[Musique]
octobre